[Music]
[Applause]
we make eye contact and the music starts
he approaches thee and invites me with
his left hand I accept and step into his
frame we begin to sway gently to the
beat getting used to our own movements
before we take some steps he steps back
making room for me to step forward so
that he stops redirecting my energy to
come back around into a turn that was
fun
and we're warming up so he tries again
but this time he leaves his hand on my
head as I keep spinning until he decides
what he wants me to stop he brings it
down those of you who know me know I
love to barter him from salsa and
bachata to ballroom and even swing I've
spent the past ten years learning
practicing and dancing all around the
world one of my favorite parts about
partner dancing is the ability to
connect with people from all walks of
life using only base level human
language eye contact and touch and yet
coming together in a flow but it can
only describe as both meditative and
energizing when I dance I understand
what they mean when they say that the
sum is greater than its part you see I
can move on my own my partner can move
on his own but then together we can do
move but neither of us could fully do on
our own I want to share with you a
different deal this time the dancefloor
is a conference room and the leader
whose moves I'm following is a VP at the
company that I work for this dance takes
place over a series of emails and
meetings and one day everything is going
great and we're on the same beat and
then the next day it feels as if I were
abandoned in the middle of the turn left
wobbling and trying to regain my balance
sounds familiar
you see new dance I have learned more
than just dance moves learning how to
partner down I have learned more about
leadership and team dynamics than in any
other class or book so today my goal is
to share with you the two best practices
but I have learned that can have the
biggest impact on your partners and your
dancing with the hopes that even if you
don't dance you can use these insights
to be a better leader at work the first
big takeaway is that you should use
energy wisely dance like most things in
life is an act of focused energy like
our friendly physicists to explain
energy cannot be created nor destroyed
only transferred or transformed the same
applies in leading and following whether
on the dance floor or in the conference
room we're always managing directing
absorbing and sharing energy even when
we're not aware that this is happening
perhaps this is why often unaware and
maybe more disconnected leaders
accidentally step on your toes they're
not aware of where their energy is going
let alone where it is in relation to
yours and before you know it goes our
big toe
so I think that leaders should manage
not just numbers and targets but also
energy let me illustrate this with an
example
I used to work at Google and at Google
unlike most companies engineers nominate
themselves for a promotion
the reason for this is that progress in
engineering can sometimes be hard to
spot externally so the onus is on the
individual to dominate him or herself
when he or she feels ready seems super
fair well the issues was that women were
not nominating themselves for promotion
at the same race that their male
colleagues were imagine you're a leader
at Google what do you do about this Alan
Eustace was a leader in the engineering
organization when he got this
information and he was really wise what
he did was he used his position to
strategically redirect the energy in the
organization he drafted an email where
he cited academic studies that show that
girls don't raise our hands as often in
the classroom and that women don't speak
up often in meetings and he said that
the same thing was happening with
promotions he sent us to every engineer
at Google and he told the women to
advocate for themselves you see in
realizing where the energy was stuck in
the organization Alan was able to use
his own leadership to pivot them to
change their behavior there are many
ways to do this you can do a more verbal
approach like Alan did you can use even
more subtle things for example if you
find that your company's being very
siloed you can organize for random desk
fridays wherever you want switches seats
and therefore talks to each other or if
you notice that everyone's really
burned-out you can give everyone a paid
day off the key seeing that I want to
encourage you to do is to use your
position as a leader to direct the
energy in the organization much like you
would in the dance the second takeaway
so the best leaders know and adapt to
their people not the other way around
we have this narrative in the world that
leadership is all about command and
control and strength and rigidity
and that is exactly the worst thing in a
dance partner the people who are
commanding and controlling their they
want to when you're dancing they just
pull you off of your foot and then you
fall or run into someone else the best
leaders are the ones who adapt
themselves to you if you're really short
they go down you're really tall they go
up they adapt it's not just about
mechanically being able to do the step
perfectly it's about how you do it with
others to put it in pecky terms good
meters are like a website that looks one
way on desktop and different on mobile
responsive leadership responsive design
so how does it actually work in practice
the best designers can tell you good
design comes from good insights good
people insight and we do this in
business in marketing and strategy and
sales we look for people insights before
we make decision but why not a
leadership we use another example this
time from Project loon which was Google
X's vicious project to send Internet up
into the air via balloons to share how a
leader might do this Astro teller was
leading the project at the time of
launch and he had a big group of
engineers and scientists everyone's
working really hard really excited to
finally launch this project it's taken
so long but there are many potential
complications with this launch and he
finds himself in a difficult position
here Astro like how could you mitigate
that risk you could delay launch and run
a bunch of tests but at the time no
longer possible you're launching in
three months so what do you do Astro
realized that he had a team full of
engineers and scientists who had become
successful by succeeding in academia
they had taken lots of tests not only
were they expert test takers but they
were proud of the fact that they were
good at taking tests so he used his
insight to create connectivity for them
he brought them all into a room give it
each a piece of paper and pen set a
timer for 30 minutes until everyone
you're taking a test whoever gets the
best answer gets the best grade you have
30 minutes you only have to answer one
question
imagine it's launch day everything goes
wrong why engineers seriously scribble
down on the paper all the reasons what
everything is going to go wrong and
before you know it in 30 minutes they
had a huge list of everything that they
needed to fix to ensure a smooth launch
but they still have three months to go
so we did it and they launched
flawlessly big takeaway here is to be
responsive to the people that you're
trying to lead adapt yourself to them
and then you're able to make the best
out of them to the untrained eye it
seems like the most technical dancer
would be the best dance partner but
that's simply not true the best dance
partners and research shows us two are
the people who are able to manage energy
effectively their own and the one energy
of others and the people who are
responsive to the behavior of their
people the best leaders have the highest
emotional intelligence or EQ so the next
time that you find yourself in the
leadership position I encourage you to
hear more than the music learn more than
steps here see the dance with the people
that you're trying to lead not only will
you spare their toes but you will also
bring the most out of the energy that
each individual has that my friends it's
how you get a guaranteed second dance
[Applause]
[Music]